old-timey Fox logo and music does not
prepare you for one of the best sci-fi
horror movies of all time still though
one of the best sci-fi horror movies of
all time so reading also its cargo is a
refinery processing 20 million tons of
mineral or I guess they invented the
perpetual motion machine between 1979
and whatever year this is also known
about space but this is one of the least
aerodynamic looking ships I've ever seen
it's like four interconnected weebles
doesn't exactly scream streamlined
spaceship half designed by mr. coffee
and the spaceship doors brought to you
by Purina who's this door opening for
the cameraman I have it on good
authority that one of these crew members
was dreaming of Electric Sheep also
given what we know about Ian Holmes
character later
how was he put under like a regular
human given that he is not one man the
Weiland corporation goes to prestige
levels of commitment to the illusion
turning the lights on full bright before
the sleeping even have a goddamn second
to wake up also are those Lilu nipple
strips of fabric that's the best way the
future space programs can think of to
cover female breasts in cryo sleep and
one inch strip of cloth you could put
full clean diapers on the men's crotches
but lady nipples I don't waste any
fabric here's a space cat no explanation
just a space cat did he have a cat size
cryo sleep chamber no clue he's just
here right now on the dinner table deal
with futuristic computers allow for
super colloquial input queries underside
of the ship decorated courtesy of one
clerk Griswold
wouldn't you think far-future spaceships
would be better equipped for landing on
strange planets than this movie suggests
one rocks everything up all these ducks
- Parker repeating the exact thing he
just said five seconds ago me we get
full shares something tells me this guy
isn't happy with the shares I don't know
what gives you that impression other
than that's been his entire dialogue for
the whole movie computer monitors often
simply just show ones and zeroes to its
users who even approved of bringing a
goddamn kitty cat to space you staticky
monitor are you in cahoots with this
movie suspense or something the ship's
hallway looks like ribs I should keep
going this is some iconic and amazing
visual brilliance let's hope no one ever
tries to explain it with the backstory
movie oh there's a giant alien skeleton
it should be evident by now they
responded to a super old outdated
distress call yet investigative bull
still goes on for a while leading to the
contamination of the ship thirty minutes
into this nightmare before someone says
something sensible transmission it looks
like a warning you mean they decided to
land on the planet walk outside and
investigate before their awesome
computer deciphered some of the message
what I know they're bound by some stupid
space rules to check out signals like
this but couldn't they have waited I
mean after finding a giant skeleton how
much more effort would you really put
into investigating this obviously dead
place the distress signal is obviously
old move along
don't go spelunking for chrissake or
something here's an alien exact thing
I'm going to touch it well he does react
to this thing opening his reaction isn't
a full speed run in the opposite
direction with a girlish scream of
Terror which earns him ascend so we are
introduced to the face hugger which is a
scary little bastard but one question do
these eggs live forever until a host
just happens to walk by
how long do these I'd been here for this
to be possible wait a minute if we let
it in the ship could be inspected I'm
gonna say bringing the guy with the
helmet alien back on the ship was a bad
idea
that science bad logic and obviously it
led to several more movies of agony that
could have been avoided and Dallas is
the captain and he's out here and he
makes the least captain II decision any
starship captain ever captain if any
asshole can simply open the door from
the outside then why did it appear that
Ripley was the only person who could
open it seems like you'd have protocols
in place to avoid like this
these dicks apparently show no fear when
it comes to face hugging aliens they
have no idea what this is but they
observe it with the calm of an ENT
checking out little Timmy's sore throat
a question better serve answered while
this dude was outside the ship no I love
the fact that this alien has such an
incredible defense mechanism how are
they able to cut this your skin if it
has the power to hold acid blood these
faces see the face hugger is not on
Kane's face anymore and just leave the
fucking door open
even Ripley who's been the most sensible
person on the ship thus far decides
forget this door to the entire ship can
just stay open we need the light from
outside because there's clearly no
lights in here for some reason this guy
falls from some sort of compartment in
the ceiling apparently just dies right
after that way to be a jump-scare dick
and death dude is it just me or is this
thing extremely vaginal looking HR Giger
was a mad genius and sinful as hell hey
we think this thing were 100% unfamiliar
with is dead even though its face hugged
our friend and bled acid let's get it
open and tinker with it by the way no
need for surgical masks guys I mean it's
a dead alien so what's the worst that
could happen also let's get right to the
alien autopsy before checking Caine
status shall we I think you should come
take a look at this cliche as his
condition changed its she just comes
here bald-faced lie if you can't explain
his condition in less time than it takes
Dallas to get down there then you're
broken and in need of serious repair
even though no one knows you're an
Android yet question oh he's awake and
doing fine eh you're right there's no
way to communicate that over a radio
Dallas did indeed 100% absolutely need
to see this to get the point so Caine is
all better now I guess we won't perform
any x-rays or tests or anything alien
species have no purpose other than being
assholes so everything should be a-okay
even if ash knows about the alien and
isn't telling anybody it's amazing
Ripley hasn't demanded does he prove his
health already and even better the cast
didn't know what's gonna happen either
me this is great anybody want to say
anything oh gee yeah I'll say something
here lies the body of a guy that could
have been left to die an hour ago on an
alien planet and probably should have
been but because we didn't let that
happen now all of us are at risk
rest in peace guy who stupidly touched
an alien X act like a Dilla hole it's
gonna be the cat gonna be the cat it's
gonna be what did I tell you so Trevor
but also how the cat even get in here
go on but be sure to find the cat by
yourself because we have lots of not
dying to do
I love how they basically sent the
creepiest asshole on this ship to go
find the cat as opposed to Ripley who
has already demonstrated a bond with the
feel on whatever we need to kill someone
and Ripley is the hero so it is what it
is holy
honestly the most sinful thing in this
whole movie is how fast this thing goes
from chestburster tiny dude to this mega
alien in size in like a few hours at
some of the most rapid growth in the
history of possibilities
alien species of all to make humans
think of sex organs just before getting
killed Monday am i right wait you saw
the alien where was that scene I thought
you would Ripley were just hanging back
with your alien detecting device letting
Brett die it's big well Cain died and
this thing popped out of him yes but I
don't think anyone benefits from
language suggesting their blood
relatives what are you an Android and
now the Nostromo it's balls heavy with
the potential ejaculate of victory over
an alien species flies its four
silhouette doors are desperately hoping
I can't keep this up I'm sorry I don't
even like this accent I'm doing can we
just cut Dallas asks mother a lot of big
questions expecting answers he might as
well just type the question why into the
computer thankfully for us the viewer
Dallas keeps his Lantern pointed at his
face instead of out in front of him and
we get some glorious facial expressions
though I have no idea how he sees where
he's going but whatever I know this air
pressure displacement detector thing
drop the alien signal a minute ago but
how does it accurately tell where Dallas
is and completely inaccurately tell
where the alien is the alien is
currently below Dallas where it's
somehow solved how to make air displace
in the floor directly above it okay so
the crew is expendable when the company
wants the alien at all costs so why was
the information that was only for the
science officer made available even if
Ripley performed an emergency override
even in a situation like this the
science officer is the only person who
needs to know this bit of information
ever
maybe this Android motherfucker move
silently maybe but the door would still
have to have opened for him to get in
here and she would definitely heard that
so do movie when an Android finally
reveals its evil nature the dramatic
wait causes white fluid to escape from
its head hmm
like just crush your skull but I will
pick the rolled-up magazine for
suffocation purposes technique the
Android medical officer is able to fight
off three able-bodied humans for a brief
time which seems that Cassidy ah the
obvious makeup head transitions to an
actual human head between cuts even
though it came out five years before the
Terminator it's way better than that
movie managed but it's still an unusual
transition so now we're at the revealing
stage of this movie's plot and I'm just
wondering if the company wants an alien
at all cost why not send qualified
personnel out on these missions why send
a ship that's hauling an oil refinery
why not put several androids on the ship
okay so maybe the movie is saying this
ship just happened to find the signal
the company was looking for and in the
event of an alien sighting go get the
alien but that doesn't explain why they
make their cruise so ill-prepared to
handle one should they run into it
chances of them bringing back a viable
organism are super low in the
Android turns into Ronald Reagan after a
punching Jones keep going back for the
cat seriously no one loves cats more
than me and this is some stupid-ass
sentimental bullet right here chance yep
she's seriously way far away from her
post right now chasing down a possible
cat I mean how fired are all these
people and how does this bastard cat
managed to make it through all these
areas of the ship with the doors closed
and I'm pretty sure this assholes
walking up and down ladders too um not
only doesn't want to kill them but he
seems to want to kill this one anally
why would you run full-speed toward the
screaming an alien carnage rather than
cutting off the bridge you were safely
on from all access points movie drama
I'm gonna go with movie drama I'm having
a hard time figuring out what a pranic
lift is or what a particle beam AB Hort
is or what a pad me it's outside the
realm of the Star Wars prequels in a
year when the Empire Strikes Back wasn't
even a thing yet so this panel is total
dork this what I'm saying decades before
she'd helped set off a self-destruct
weapon for comedy sake and Galaxy Quest
Sigourney Weaver was setting off
self-destruct weapons and movies for the
purpose of story and they're pushing
these futures to candles actually speeds
up their descent or else the movie is
relying on some pretty cliche means of
conveying how desperate its main
character is just survive the alien
which is weird because four seasons of
valve told me that that was their
favorite food oh so the cat goes in the
hibernation chamber too it's amazing
they have the technology to correctly
slow down the metabolism of both humans
and cats in the same chamber at the same
time which is how it's supposedly went
down at the beginning of the movie yes
there's still an alien fight left but it
absolutely must wait until she's in her
underwear duh
also guys there's no such thing as
subtle exploitation how the hell did
this thing get onboard and if so why
didn't it kill Ripley before she took
off there's this movie saying the alien
crawled through a duct of some sort
while she flew away from the main ship
this has always puzzled me when it comes
to the before and after if before she
should be dead if after I don't see how
the alien got inside its alien 22 that
engine burst really totally killed that
alien but also put you on a direct
course for the restaurant at the end of
the universe so
it's drinking the water
I don't tip you don't tip I don't
believe in it you don't believe in
tipping you know what these chicks make
morning mother
I'm sorry Dave some of you may have
figured out we're not home yet only
halfway there
anybody hungry surprise cock bags the
world isn't run by weapons anymore or
energy or money it's run by little ones
and zeros little bits of data it's all
just electron weight
there's no Dana only Zuul